la branche rebelle à metz et vittel
comme on dit on ferait bien la dernière
on n'aime pas gagné par forfait il
faudrait que je trouve un nouveau
partenaire quitte ou double ça vous va
monsieur oui vous là comment vous vous
appelez manque dargis m'appelle mais
tout le monde et je m'appelle moment
momo c'est superbe
j'aime beaucoup vous savez jouer à la
pétanque monsieur vos moules yapi tanks
mais c'est rien c'est comme le bia met
par terre c'est difficile mais non c'est
simple un voilà tu prends et tu sais pas
s'il y arrive je vous la coupe succès
thon rouge elle aimait qu'il faut
cracher au bassinet maintenant
à
vas-y mon nom sur l'accent bien sûr on
croyait qu'il fout de la gueule des
arabes